The world is an unpredictable place. That's
what makes it so haunting when you watch a
movie years after it's come out, and you realize
that the filmmakers unintentionally predicted
real-world tragedies. You'll never be able
to watch these movies the same way again.
Game Of Death
Game of Death was released in 1978, five years
after its lead actor, Bruce Lee, had died.
But the completed movie, which was rewritten
after Lee died of unrelated medical complications
during the production, contains a truly eerie
plot point. Lee plays Billy Lo, an actor who's
shot with a prop gun that turns out to have
a real bullet in it. The shot isn't fatal,
but Lo fakes his death to take revenge on
the would-be assassins.
In 1993, Bruce Lee's son, Brandon Lee, died
while filming The Crow. An actor was supposed
to fire an unloaded gun at Brandon, but a
bullet fragment that was previously stuck
in the barrel dislodged while shooting the
blank cartridge. It struck Brandon with same
velocity as a real round. Brandon Lee died
under nearly the same circumstances depicted
in his father's final movie.
Demolition Man
Demolition Man from 1993 predicted a high
profile murder nearly a decade before it happened.
The sci-fi film involved a "cryo-prison" where
criminals are frozen and put in cold storage.
At one point in the movie, the prisoners who
are frozen with Stallone's character and the
criminal he caught appear on a jailhouse monitor.
One of the names that pops up is "Scott Peterson"—a
name probably chosen by an intern or low level
production assistant
Fewer than ten years later, in 2002, a woman
named Laci Peterson was brutally murdered
by her husband: Scott Peterson. He was convicted
of killing Laci and their unborn son in 2004,
and was sentenced to death a year later. In
the years after his conviction and sentencing,
he was a death row inmate in California's
San Quentin prison. Meanwhile, the cryo-prison
in Demolition Man was where California kept
their worst prisoners—their death row inmates.
The Matrix
To say the prop designer on the set of The
Matrix from 1999 may have inadvertently predicted
the worst act of terror inflicted on the United
States of America is both unnerving and, more
importantly, not meant to show disrespect
to any of the fallen. However, when watching
the movie now, it's difficult to ignore the
expiration date on Thomas "Neo" Anderson's
passport, which is 9/11/01.
Poltergeist
Poltergeist is spooky enough, but it doesn't
end there. The children's room includes a
fake Superbowl 22 poster, which would be
happening in 1988, six years after the movie
debuted in theaters. Weirdly enough, that
poster inadvertently predicted when Heather
O'Rourke, the child star who's abducted by
ghosts in the movie, would become fatally
sick. As Superbowl 22 came around on January
31, 1988, O'Rourke fell violently ill before
passing away the next day due to a cardiac
arrest triggered by an intestinal stenosis.
World's Greatest Dad
In 2009's World's Greatest Dad, Robin Williams
plays Lance Clayton, a dad and English teacher
whose teenage son accidentally dies from autoerotic
asphyxiation. Clayton, not wanting the police
or anyone else to find his son's body like
that, makes it look like a suicide instead.
Williams' portrayal of Clayton, combined with
his heartfelt characters who dealt with suicide
in What Dreams May Come, Patch Adams, and
Dead Poets Society, makes his tragic suicide
in 2014 stand out even more.
Thanks for watching. Subscribe to our YouTube
channel to watch more videos like the one
you just saw.